weihnachten in der pandemie viele tests
viel weniger reisende und wieder ein
neuer höchststand bei den todeszahlen
virus risiko in den kirchen die amds
ärzte in deutschland fordern alle
feiertags gottesdienste mit besuchern
abzusagen und schlussphase im wechsel
streit ein handelsabkommen zwischen
großbritannien und der eu steht offenbar
kurz vor dem abschluss
nachrichten des tages heute mit
christian sievers meine damen und herren
guten abend sport in der sendung nachher
mit kristin otto in 15 minuten genannt
der tag vor heiligabend in einem land
das besorgt auf die daten schaut die
unseren alltag bestimmen und dieses jahr
es ist wieder ein tag mit traurigen
rekorden in deutschland sterben aktuell
so viele menschen in verbindung mit dem
corona virus wie an keinem anderen tag
in dieser pandemie
das zeigt wie massiv sich das virus
ausbreiten konnte innerhalb eines tages
hat das robert-koch-institut 962
todesfälle registriert damit steigt die
zahl derer die diese pandemie nicht
überlebt haben
auf 27 1968 menschen und die zahl der
positiv tests bleibt hoch die
gesundheitsämter meldeten 24.700 40 neue
fälle an einem tag die situation fasst
david sauer zusammen
große hoffnung im kleinen ampullen diese
laster verteilen den pfizer biontech
impfstoff vom werk in belgien an die eu
länder schneller als gedacht könnte die
impfung allen zur verfügung stehen wenn
alle aussichtsreichen phase drei
impfstoffe zur zulassung kommen dann
können wir richtung sommer allen ein
empfang gebot machen
weihnachten steht jetzt vor der tür und
viele wollen ihre familien treffen
lassen sich vorsichtshalber testen
kostenlose schnelltests für alle gibt es
heute und morgen in baden württemberg
zwischen natürlich immer wieder positive
raus und die gehen schon mal nicht
sicher ob mutter oder vater verzicht der
leben retten kann
denn trotz shutdowns ist bundesweit noch
keine trendwende absehbar
die einschränkungen könnten noch eine
ganze weile bestehen bleiben wir werden
auf den zehn januar die maßnahmen noch
nicht wieder zurücknehmen können weil
das infektionsgeschehen dort eindeutig
noch zu hoch sein wird von daher ist es
noch lange zeit durchhalten auch den
januar entdeckt und auch der
lehrerverband glaubt nicht an
regelunterricht nach den ferien werden
auch ab mitte januar noch mit einer
längeren phase an wechsel unterricht
oder hybrid unterricht oder auch distanz
lernen leben müssen
währenddessen müssen sie im sächsischen
zittau die toten hier draußen lagern
weil die menschen schneller sterben als
das krematorium sie einäschern kann
im vergleich zum vorjahresmonat gab es
hier im dezember schon mehr als doppelt
so viele tote und der monat ist noch
nicht vorbei
[Applaus]
wegen der alarmierenden zahlen werden
jetzt immer mehr gottesdienste an
weihnachten gestrichen
der verband der amtsärzte und einige
politiker fordern ein generelles verbot
dabei hatten sich viele kirchengemeinden
darauf vorbereitet die gottesdienste so
abzuhalten dass sie den chor ohne regeln
entsprechen
draußen mit wenigen teilnehmern mit
abstand und anmeldepflicht was die
gläubigen jetzt an den feiertagen
erwartet zeigt oliver deuker die
marktkirche hannover nun mit
einlasskarten und unter den
hygieneregeln dürfen die verkürzten
weihnachtsgottesdienste besucht werden
doch gottesdienst den crooner zeiten
sind umstritten
ich kann nicht auf einer seite sagen
gruppe meiden und sagen du kannst in die
kirche gehen also es ist schon wichtig
auch mal wieder rauszugehen und gerade
an so einem speziellen weihnachten wo
man nicht zur familie fährt wo man
wirklich sich komplett einschränkt und
das ist sozusagen das ja der
weihnachtsstern denn der einzige dem man
so hat in der st johannes gemeinde
hannover sollten mehrere kurze
weihnachtsgottesdienste stattfinden
allerdings nur draußen mit
entsprechendem hygiene konzept wegen der
befürchtung dass sich die besucher vor
nach dem gottesdienst zu nahe kommen
könnten wurde alles abgesagt menschen zu
enttäuschen die kommen wollten
das ist traurig und das war für den
gesamten kirchenvorstand eine traurige
entscheidung wir haben sie gemeinsam
getroffen weil wir es für
menschenfreundlichere variante dieses
jahr halten der mariendom im bistum
hildesheim hier werden gottesdienste
stattfinden die drei heiligabend messen
sind schon ausgebucht wir haben viel
erfahrung im umgang mit strengen
hygienevorschriften von daher kann ich
mut machen gottesdienste zu besuchen
natürlich sind gottesdienste wichtig
aber auch eine gefahr betonen dagegen
gesundheit 6
das problem ist wenn die leute
zusammenkommen ob in großen draußen
veranstaltungen oder in kleineren engen
räumen das virus geht mit dem menschen
mit und es verbreitet sich auch von
mensch zu mensch und das müssen wir in
den blick nehmen ein tipp für die die
lieber zu hause bleiben wollen das zdf
überträgt morgen um 1915 einen vor
aufgezeichneten gottesdienst aus der
saalkirche ingelheim und das ist morgen
direkt nach dieser heute sendung
nordrhein westfalens ministerpräsident
armin laschet hat fehler der politik
während der korona pandemie eingeräumt
und dafür ausdrücklich um verzeihung
gebeten
im frühjahr als die heime abgeriegelt
waren hätten viele menschen nicht von
ihren angehörigen abschied nehmen können
laschet sagte dem spiegel wörtlich das
ist ein schaden den wir nicht wieder
gutmachen können bleiben wir bei diesen
schicksalen die sich hinter all den
täglichen zahlen daten fakten verbergen
wenn menschen an corona sterben dann
hofft einsam einige angehörige können
nicht bei ihnen sein
die vorsichtsmassnahmen verbieten ist
und so bleiben auch kinder geschwister
ehepartner allein mit ihrem schmerz
cornelia schiemenz cordula es wurde 61
jahre alt sie starb am 16 november an
einer corona infektion zurück bleiben
ihr mann und ihre 14-jährige
pflegetochter oft kommen die beiden nun
zum kleinen dorf friedhof im sächsischen
großröhrsdorf trauer also nicht
verstehen also es kommt wahrscheinlich
mit der zeit also jetzt schon nicht mehr
so schlimm wie am anfang aber am anfang
war es eben sehr schlimm
16 jahre waren die rechtsanwältin und
der molekularbiologe verheiratet wo sich
cordula hess mit dem tödlichen virus
infiziert hat weiß winfried
rommerskirchen nicht wahrscheinlich war
es auf einer gemeinsamen zugfahrt ende
oktober auch er erkrankte durfte deshalb
seine todkranke frau nicht mehr sehen
pflegetochter jasmin besuchte cordula es
noch einmal in der uniklinik dresden
war traurig ich habe wollte es gar nicht
wahr handels dass sie jetzt so liegt
dort habe ich dann auch als ich in dem
zimmer war auch angefangen zu weinen
cordula hess war stadträtin
sozialdemokraten aus leidenschaft eine
lebensfrohe fröhliche frau so behält sie
ihr mann in erinnerung dass gerade in
sachsen viele menschen das virus leugnen
macht winfried rommerskirchen
ich kann überhaupt nicht verstehen zum
teil denken sie wahrscheinlich ist alles
lüge
es war nun kommt weihnachten das erste
fest ohne cordula hess winfried
rommerskirchen jasmin theinert werden
sich gegenseitig liebe und halt geben
mehr zum thema kroner nachher in dieser
sendung jetzt ein dauerthema der brh
exit es deutet sich aber jetzt
tatsächlich immer mehr an dass beide
parteien kurz vor einer einigung stehen
seit monaten verhandeln die eu und
großbritannien über einen handelsvertrag
für die zeit ab ersten januar dann endet
die praxis übergangsphase gibt es keinen
vertrag droht ein harter
wirtschaftlicher bruch zum jahresende
stefan leifert beobachtet all das für
uns in brüssel gute namen stefan ja was
sagt uns denn dass es jetzt tatsächlich
soweit ist und ein brett citydeal
wirklich kommt angekündigt war ja schon
sehr oft wenn das jetzt wirklich so
kommt und danach sieht es aus dann läge
der wert dieser einigung vor allem darin
dass in buchstäblich allerletzter
sekunde der harte bruch also das no deal
szenario doch noch abgewendet werden
konnte denn wenn die nächsten stunden
oder der laufe der nacht jetzt eine
einigung bringen dann würde die eu
gleich schon morgen früh ein verfahren
in gang setzen was diesen rexit vertrag
dann vorläufig zum ersten ersten in
kraft setzt vorläufig deswegen weil die
beiden parlamente auf beiden seiten noch
zustimmen müssten
dafür würde dann die zeit fehlen das
müsse nachgeholt werden aber der vertrag
könnte am 11
in kraft treten offenbar haben die
letzten stunden die entscheidende
annäherung beim thema der
fischereirechte gebracht darüber wird
jetzt hier
der kommission hinter mir noch in den
letzten zügen verhandelt ein konsens
gibt es wohl schon bei der großen und so
umstrittenen frage der gleichen
wettbewerbsbedingungen
das kann jetzt also eine sache von
stunden seinen sagen beide seiten wenn
das wirklich so kenne dann würden damit
dreieinhalb jahre
erste verhandlungen mit einem happy end
in allerletzter sekunde zu ende gehen
wir sind gespannt stefan vielen dank
nach brüssel
in washington gibt es streit noch
präsident donald trump ist so nicht
einverstanden mit dem chor ohne
hilfspaket dass der us-kongress gerade
beschlossen hat es geht um 900
milliarden dollar für bedürftige für
betriebe und für den kampf gegen korona
in einer videobotschaft nannte trump das
paket eine schande ist sei teilweise
verschwenderisch und die hilfszahlungen
müssten höher ausfallen
demokraten und republikaner hatten sich
nach langem gezerre auf das hilfspaket
geeinigt jetzt aber verzögert sich das
ganze weiter zum vierten mal innerhalb
von zwei jahren muss in israel ein neues
parlament gewählt werden weil sich die
regierungsparteien nicht auf einen
haushalt einigen konnten hatte sich das
parlament um mitternacht automatisch
aufgelöst
hintergrund ist ein seit monaten
andauernde streit zwischen
ministerpräsident benjamin netanjahu und
seinem koalitionspartner benny gantz vor
fünf jahren veröffentlichte der
türkische journalist john denver einen
brisanten zeitungsartikel
darin ging es um illegale
waffenlieferungen der türkei nach syrien
dündar geriet damit ins fadenkreuz des
türkischen präsidenten und der justiz
der vorwurf terror unterstützung und
spionage
ein gericht in istanbul hat ihn deswegen
jetzt zu einer langen haftstrafe
verurteilt in abwesenheit jörg brase
berichtet
in seinem exil in berlin erfuhr agenda
von dem urteil des gerichts in istanbul
ein urteil das er erwartet hatte 27
einhalb jahre wegen unterstützung einer
terrorgruppe und wegen spionage
der grund zu panik sie wollten die
journalisten die damals die geschichte
geschrieben hat und hart bestrafen so
dass niemand es wagen würde je wieder
eine solche geschichte zu
veröffentlichen
ich zahle den preis dafür dass ich die
wahrheit erzählt es ging um einen
bericht über illegale waffenlieferungen
der türkischen regierung an syrische
rebellen im jahr 2014
denn da war damals chefredakteur der
zeitung cumhuriyet der bericht wurde nie
widerlegt trotzdem wurden er und ein
kollege später angeklagt und verurteilt
du das vermögen in der türkei wurde
beschlagnahmt kritiker sehen darin eine
hexenjagd mit system alle wichtigen
politischen prozesse vor dem istanbuler
gericht gehen an den selben richter und
derselbe richter verhängt die höchsten
strafen das kann kein zufall sein dass
anwälte sprachen von einem schauprozess
vor dem gericht in istanbul und blieben
aus protest der heutigen
urteilsverkündung fern
das urteil gegen chen gründer ist auch
ein zeichen an regime-gegner dass sie
nicht auf gnade hoffen dürfen
oppositionspolitiker bleiben in haft
trotz der forderungen europäischer
gerichte sie freizulassen und viele
regierungskritiker wie die agenda
bleiben im exil außenminister maas
kritisierte das heutige urteil als
schlag gegen unabhängige journalistische
arbeit in der türkei und damit in dieser
sendung zurück zum thema kroner
verschiedene mutationen des virus haben
in den letzten tagen für ziemliches
chaos im internationalen verkehr gesorgt
vor allem die reisewege von und nach
großbritannien wurden vorsichtshalber
dicht gemacht und deshalb sitzen an der
südküste von england zigtausende lkw
fahrer fest darunter auch mehrere
hundert deutsche zwar erlaubt frankreich
seit mitternacht wieder die einreise
allerdings nur mit negativem corona test
etliche fahrer machen ihrem ärger luft
weil sie fürchten jetzt weihnachten im
lkw verbringen zu müssen
in großbritannien wurde unterdessen eine
weitere
aktionen des virus entdeckt die der
gesundheitsminister sehr beunruhigend
nennt und die aus südafrika stammt damit
sich der erreger von dort aus nicht
weiter ausbreitet gilt auch für dieses
land für südafrika ein flugverbot nach
deutschland andere länder in europa
handhaben das anders in südafrika geht
nicht nur die sorge um vor dem neuen
corona virusvariante sondern auch vor
den folgen eines möglichen neuen
lockdown sandra teils der flughafen in
johannesburg so gut wie leer
seit bekannt ist dass in südafrika eine
neue corona variante wütet haben
zahlreiche länder den flugverkehr ganz
oder teilweise eingestellt darunter auch
deutschland viele reisende sitzen fest
auch familie wesolowski aus berlin
sie sind trotz reisewarnung nach
südafrika geflogen jetzt wissen sie
nicht wie sie zurückkommen
ich hätte nicht gedacht dass der
flugverkehr so betroffen sein wird das
ist schockierend und ich weiß nicht wie
es jetzt weiter geht die neue
virusvariante tauchte im september
erstmals in südafrika auf sagen forscher
seitdem habe sie sich im ganzen land
verbreitet
es ist definitiv nicht dieselbe variante
wie in großbritannien
aber die varianten haben gemeinsamkeiten
sie haben eine spezielle mutation der
stirn virus erlaubt sich besser an die
menschliche zelle in der lunge
anzuheften und schneller einzubringen
diese mutation ist offenbar der grund
warum sich das virus viel schneller
ausbreitet schon jetzt haben manche
krankenhäuser ihre belastungsgrenze
erreicht oder sogar überschritten
die ausbreitung kann wohl nur ein harter
lockdown eindämmen
doch die regierung zögert denn beim
ersten lockdown ging millionen jobs
verloren ein weiterer würde noch mehr
menschen in die armut treiben zurück
nach deutschland auf den straßen den
gleisen und in der luft heute deutlich
weniger menschen unterwegs als
eigentlich üblich am tag vor heiligabend
in einem jahr in dem politik und virus
experten abraten von familientreffen zum
fest
wird vom weihnachts reiseverkehr einiges
abhängen denken klinge auch bei regen
und schlechter sicht kommen die
autofahrer heute gut durch am größten
verkehrsknotenpunkt deutschlands dem
frankfurter kreuz der normale
vorweihnachtliche stau richtung
skigebiete fällt in diesem jahr aus und
so wird es wohl auch bleiben
aufgrund des kroner locker und spendet
deutlich weniger verkehrsaufkommen und
damit auch staus an den feiertagen haben
allerdings wären viele leute zu den
verwandten fahren oder in
naherholungsgebieten da sollte man
vorher schauen wie dichter verkehr dort
ist am frankfurter flughafen wollen
einen tag vor heiligabend immerhin rund
40.000 menschen verreisen
im letzten jahr waren es aber viermal so
viele
meine frau sagt kämmerin und ihre
familie runter und das haben wir sind ja
ziemlich gesehen und jetzt liegen wir
über auch am frankfurter hauptbahnhof
ist deutlich weniger los als sonst
wir erwarten etwa 30 35 prozent
auslastung in den fernzügen
an manchen tagen in der spitze auch mal
60 prozent zum beispiel am heutigen 23
dabei hat es sich so ein bisschen aber
ansonsten wird sich der verkehr
entzerren
fernreisende überlegen aktuell offenbar
genau wohin sie fahren
das wissen die patchwork familie und wir
haben uns auch auf twitter und wir
werden auch nicht zu meinen großeltern
geht trotz geringerer auslastung hat die
bahn 100 sonderzüge eingesetzt damit die
reisenden mit dem ausreichenden abstand
an ihr ziel kommen können
das war die situation beim verkehr jetzt
kommt die lage in dem sport christi das
wirst du ein stück normalität dfb pokal
teil 1 zweite runde mit dem ausschuss
zwei erstligisten union berlin verlor
gegen paderborn 2 zu 3 und hoffenheim in
einem typischen pokalfight gegen
greuther fürth mit 6 7 im
elfmeterschießen die entscheidung
zugunsten des zweitliga vereins fiel
erst durch den achtzehnten schützen
maierhofers weihnachts treffer beschert
zweitligist führt den einzug in die
dritte pokalrunde ein krimi der diese
bezeichnung verdient favorit erstligist
hoffenheim geht in führung minuten
später der ausgleich des zweitligisten
durch sebastian ernst zweite hälfte
zuerst führung der gäste vom
klassenunterschied keine spur
hoffenheim gleicht wieder aus die
spannung steigt zudem durch ein in der
nachspielzeit vergebenen elfmeter happy
end für den andere dort erst durch den
goldenen treffer
eine schöne bescherung für greuther
fürth 500 slalom der weltcup-geschichte
und platz sechs für linus strasser nach
einer mehr als drei monate langen
verletzungspause zeigte sich der
münchner beim nachtrennen von madonna di
campiglio zitat mega happy über seine
top ten platzierung
tagessieger wurde der norweger hinrik
kristofferson gut gespielt dennoch
verloren
der einstand des deutschen basketball
stars dennis schröder bei den los
angeles lakers zum verspäteten auftakt
der neuen nba saison war durchaus
sehenswert doch sein team unterlag dem
stadt-rivalen das erste zuspiel von
lebron james ging an dennis schröder und
die ersten punkte für die lakers auf
schröders konto von beginn an in der
startaufstellung wirbelte der deutsche
nationalspieler kräftig auf dem parkett
schröder lieferte 14 punkte und eine
glänzende leistung für seinen neuen
verein die treue ich habe versucht mein
spiel zu bieten wir hatten ja insgesamt
nur zehn tage vorbereitung als team den
saisonauftakt haben die lakers gegen die
los angeles clippers mit 109 zu 116
verloren ein schlechter start für den
titelverteidiger aber nicht für den ist
schröder
immerhin würde ich dann ja hast du lust
auf lottozahlen christin immer immer da
kann ich liefern
die gewinnzahlen lauten 11 12 13 37 38
39 super 27 und weitere gewinnzahlen
auch wie immer auf lotto zdf de und im
zdf text auf seite 55 7
der dezember ist ja bislang sehr mild
aber das wird sich jetzt zu weihnachten
für einige ändern katja horneffer hat
sogar schnee im angebot um 21 45 hat der
kollege claus kleber fragen an den chef
von bayern keck wir alle hier im heute
themen sind selbstverständlich auch
morgen für sie da an heiligabend wie
immer punkt 19 uhr bis dann also ich
wünsche ihnen einen angenehmen